incredibly important part of Ramadan,
the zakat, the poor Jew, as it's
sometimes translated. And this is really
the first point of order today, which is
to discuss the meaning of the term
zakat, sometimes zaka, and to discuss if
we could some of the significance of uh
the term zakat in Islam.
Alhamdulillah.
As far as the literal meaning of the
word zakat is concerned, zakat is
derived from the Arabic word zaka which
means to purify which means to increase.
It also means blessings and goodness. So
zaka means purification or cleanliness,
increase, it means goodness. It means
blessings. In Islamic Sharia, zaka is an
obligatory charity which every Muslim
who has a saving or a surplus wealth
which has reached the nisab level or
above that and stays with him for one
complete lunar year or one hij year he
should give zakat on that surplus wealth
which is most of the time 2 and a half%.
This is the Sharia Islamic meaning of
it. And Allah subhanaa t says in the
Quran in surah tba chapter number n
verse number 103
take arms or give charity give zakat
from the wealth so that it will purify
and sanctify them. Allah says in the
Quran in surah room chapter number 30
verse number 39
those who give gifts in order that it
will increase their property through the
gifts of the other person's property it
will have no increase with Allah
subhanana wa tala but those who give
charity seeking the pleasure of Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala they will find an
increased herin
and zakat is one of the pillars of Islam
Our beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in Sai Bkari volume number one
in the book of Im book of faith hadith
number eight Muhammad sallallahu alaihi
wasallam said that Islam is based on
five principles the first isallahu
there's no god but Allah and prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him is the
messenger of Allah the second is
establishing salah third is giving zakat
that is obligated charity the fourth is
performing Hajj and fifth is fasting the
month of Ramadan which all of us are
doing. Alhamdulillah. Now so zakat is
one of the important pillars of Islam.
There are various verses of zakat which
tell us what zakat is even various
hadith which give significance in Islam.
Allah says in surah anfal chapter number
8 verse number three and four that zakat
is a sign of belief. It says that all
those who believe and establish salah
and give zakat they are the true
believers. That mean zakat is a sign of
true belief.
And a beloved prophet wasallam said it's
mentioned in say Muslim volume number
four had number 6264
he said that
when you give charity it does not
decrease the wealth.
And if a servant of Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala if he forgives Allah subhanana wa
ta'ala increases respect
and if he shows humility then Allah
subhanana wa ta'ala raises his status in
the eyes of the people. So charity does
not decease the wealth. It rather
increases the wealth
and by zakat there is unity and
brotherhood among the Muslim ummah.
The full Muslim ummah throughout the
world is like one family and a person
cares for the others. The rich men they
give zakat to the poor and they feel
they're as though they are part of one
family. And the beloved prophet wasallam
said it's mentioned in sai bkari volume
number one in the book of salah had
number 481.
Muhammad sallallahu alaihi wasallam said
that one faithful believer
to another faithful believer is like the
bricks of the ball. They support each
other like the bricks of the ball. and
he interlaced his fingers
of his hands like that. So it brings
unity in the Muslim ummah
and there's one more verse in the Quran
which describes zakat in a nutshell.
Allah says in surah al hash chapter
number 59 verse number 7 speaking about
zakat that it prevents the wealth from
circulating amongst the rich.
So it is sort of an economic order in
Islam.